so i heard that your daughters were
impressed that you got to meet the guy
who made encanto
well listen so we had the sag awards and
we didn't we spent the whole sunday
morning with the kids and then had to go
pretty early start getting ready for the
sag awards and we like like mummy and
daddy are going out tonight and they're
like no no we don't want you anyway this
whole meltdown we're like listen we
might meet guess who we might meet and
they're like hey we're like lin-manuel
miranda and they were like no and i was
like yeah we'll see anyway so we go to
it and lin-manuel
comes up to me
is like
he's with my andrew garfield who's one
of my best friends obviously they worked
together on the antique boom so andrew
brought him up and then basically had
seen this movie i did call barbara star
go to vista del mar he's seen it over 10
times so he was one coming up to me i
like blew my kid's mind we're obsessed
with him in the house obsessed with
encanto oh my god
like obsessed so i think any yes any
person with children yeah you know
bruno you know
you know all the songs yeah and
constantly
at home watching it and then in the car
and then in your car it's the soundtrack
yeah i'm fine with it i am too really
good with it and i should hate it by now
no you can't hate it i should seriously
have a loathing like tim mcgraw don't
take the girl back in the 90s they
played that song too much i should have
like a kind of a hatred for it at this
point and i don't but that's a measure
of how good the songs are that they
don't grate on you even if you learn
them all the time
yeah and it's kind of cool too like to
be that talented to impress people with
hamilton adults make grown people cry
and then touch kids like that that's a
rare town yeah
but i love that he was like impressed
right now that's a good feeling it was
great it was mine you're like wait you
you're impressed by me okay i'm done all
right yeah yeah i love that feeling
[Music]
you